the phrase represents the new movement
that has taken over the streets of Haiti
people are tired of gangs controlling
their lives and that's why they decided
to start fighting back
[Music]
jean-baptist Kenley says the movement
will get bigger every day
it's a campaign of vaccination against
gang violence the boy kalei will
continue to eradicate the kidnapping
virus in the country
gangs now control 80 of Haiti's capital
and they're extending their presence to
other parts of the country
people say they have had enough and have
started to go after gang members
some have been set on fire on the
streets
chaos has taken over this Caribbean
Nation
neighborhoods like this one have been
transformed by the violence in the past
months I'm here in the neighborhood of
Bel-Air this area used to be filled with
people but as you can see right now it's
almost empty it looks like a war zone
there's been fighting going on between
rival gangs we're told that members of
the G9 gang are not far away from here
and they have been attacking this area
yeah yeah
Emmanuel showed us around the area he
says gangs are ruthless
they have set on fire houses here they
also rape and kill
he also says the government has
benefited from them I want the situation
change but I know the Haitian government
doesn't want because it's good for him
the politician
are the father of gangsters need
the United Nations says the violence has
increased malnourishment in the country
by 30 percent
over one hundred thousand children are
at risk of dying because of hunger the
interim prime minister Ariel Enrique has
requested urgent International
assistance to help the government fight
the gangs
even though it's been six months since
the request was made there has not been
an answer this should be a force a
multilateral force with the leadership
of one country whatever country
unfortunately there's no country who has
been able to accept this this great
challenge
and so now we are at the point that we
require innovative ways to find
different solutions
while the International Community
continues debating what to do about
Haiti people have been left on their own
going after those who hurt them and
waiting for a solution that never seems
to arrive
there is